BEN GABLE: OK, everybody.
As Bill mentioned,
my name is Ben Gable.
I'm a partner developer advocate
and game developer at Google.
And I am working on the
initiative of Chromebooks
and games on Chromebooks.
And basically, we're super
excited about this opportunity.
And we're going to go over
the Chrome OS, a little bit
overview of the Chrome OS.
Then we're going to hear
from Daniel about Star Wars:
Galaxy of Heroes and
how they optimized
the game for Chromebooks.
And then I'm going
to talk a little bit
about the technical
overview of things
you might look out
for when optimizing
your game for Chromebooks.
So as I mentioned, as some of
you might know or may not know,
all Chromebooks launched in 2017
and later now contain ARC++.
And so they've got a Android
container running in it.
And they can play Android
apps and games natively.
So it's super exciting
because now you
can play it on
your mobile device
and on a PC like form factor.
And this is something that's
important because it's not just
Chromebooks.
There's a push, I think,
in the entire industry
where we're pushing towards
this Universal App type
thing where you can play
on your mobile device.
You can play using like Samsung
DeX on a PC type experience.
So it's important to think
about this moving forward
that users are really
going to expect
to play their game on the go
and then maybe at home plug
into some device or load it
up on another different form
factor device and
continue playing
from where they left off.
And, of course,
we're all gamers.
So I think some
of us might argue
that playing on a keyboard and
mouse is the only way to play--
so super exciting for
that reason as well.
Just a little bit about
the momentum of Chromebook.
So this just rolled out in 2017.
And we overtook Macs
in the US in 2016.
It's a huge player in
the educational space,
so a lot of schools
are buying Chromebooks,
obviously not to play games
on them, but, you know, hey.
And it's growing, and Google
is putting in a lot of effort
in making Chromebooks
a huge success.
And so some of the
common issues that we
run into when we optimize
Android apps for Chromebooks
is, obviously, you've
got a bigger screen,
increased resolutions.
You're at default
landscape orientation
now, instead of portrait.
You've got windowing to
take into consideration.
And then also you've got
keyboard and mouse controls.
And while these are
common issues, for games,
there's a lot of opportunity.
So you can avoid "hand-claw"
playing these hi-fi immersive
games that kind of now you
could play for hours on end.
You can avoid
cramping your hand.
You've got a bigger screen.
So UI is more readable.
It does its job better.
It's more functional.
And obviously,
keyboard and mouse
means you've got more
accessibility, better controls,
especially in
competitive type games,
or really any type of game.
But we've got somebody here
who has more experience
and can give us a firsthand
look at how they optimize it.
So I'd like to welcome
Daniel up from EA.
And he's going to talk
about how they optimized
"Star Wars, Galaxy of Heroes"
to make an awesome Chromebook
experience.
DANIEL R. LEVY: All right.
Thank you, Ben.
BEN GABLE: Yep.
DANIEL R. LEVY: All
right, I'm Daniel Levy
with Electronic Arts.
And I work on "Star
Wars, Galaxy of Heroes."
Recently, I've had the
exciting opportunity
to work with Ben to get
"Star Wars, Galaxy of Heroes"
Chromebook ready.
Now, out of the box, if
you've got a Unity title,
you are going to be
pretty far along in terms
of what you need to do to
support the Chromebook.
But we're going to go over
today a few best practices
and key considerations
that we've
learned at Electronic Arts
when designing new features
and retrofitting existing
features for the Chromebook
platform.
So just a little
bit of background,
if you're not familiar with
"Star Wars, Galaxy of "Heroes,"
we provide a mobile CCG,
Collectible Card Game,
Collectible Character Game,
with strong RPG elements
and mechanics.
We let players collect their
favorite characters and ships
across a wide
variety of timelines
within the entire
"Star Wars" universe.
Through our use of
the Unity game engine,
we support iOS, Android, and,
as we'll see, the Chromebook.
Though our worldwide launch
was in November of 2015,
more recently in
November of 2017,
we've added support for
keyboard-focused features,
which we'll get into
in a second here.
So if you're an
existing live title,
you're probably
thinking, why would I
retrofit keyboard support?
Why would I rethink
the features in my game
and engineer them and redesign
them around keyboards?
There's quite a bit of
technical jargon here,
but really the core
is consistently
we've seen month
over month of growth
in key indicators that are
important to game developers.
Our daily active
users on Chromebook
have grown month over month.
And we've also
seen just specific
to the Chromebook platform
our gross revenue increase.
And again, as we stated earlier,
if you're a Unity title,
you're 80% of the way there to
supporting a great experience
on the Chromebook platform.
Now, you're probably
thinking, this
sounds great, how do I start
redesigning my features
or integrating support for new
features around the Chromebook
platform?
There are a couple of
pillars that we consider
in redesigning and
creating new features that
are keyboard-focused.
One of the key things--
and this is going to
seem somewhat obvious,
but keep it in mind--
focus on wide audience value.
What do we mean by
wide audience value?
If you're designing a
new feature in your game,
don't design that
feature such that it's
entirely specific to
keyboard functionality.
Think about new
features when you're
supporting keyboard
functionality that add value
to both existing
users of your game
and new players that are
going to want to interact
with your game on a keyboard.
This provides an
easy justification
to your development team and
makes this side quest easier
to justify in terms
of development cost.
Another important item to
note, look at existing features
and functionality in your game.
You might have a lot of existing
features, such as in-game chat,
that are so close to being
ready for a great keyboard
experience.
Take those features,
don't ignore polish,
and take them to the next
level, so that you can provide
a great keyboard experience.
Now-- and this is important to
any level of game development--
listen to your player base.
You'll be surprised.
If you go on the "Star
Wars, Galaxy of Heroes"
subreddit and you search for
Android emulator or keyboard,
you're going to find
a plethora of posts
from users talking about macros
that they've set up in game
or how they're engaging with
the game using a keyboard.
We'll see a specific
example later on,
where we drew from this
player-base feedback
to design one of our
keyboard first features.
So our first case study
here is roster search.
This is, to me, an
excellent example
of a way that we're able
to provide wide audience
value in our game.
We both provided value for
non-keyboard users and keyboard
users.
If you've played
"Star Wars, Galaxy
of Heroes," or for
that matter any CCG,
you know that there's a strong
collection mechanic here.
"Star Wars, Galaxy of Heroes"
has hundreds of characters,
hundreds of ships.
And each of those
characters and ships
have a unique set
of abilities that
have a unique way of
interacting with combat
mechanics in the game.
Even more so, we design events
and raids that specifically key
off of those certain
ability mechanics
of certain characters.
So a lot of times,
we would find players
would go into a certain event,
and they would ask, hey,
what are the best
set of characters
that I want to bring into
my squad for this event?
They would analyze
the meta, they'd
understand what to do with
respect to that event.
But then they would get down
to the actual squad selection,
and they would find themselves
inundated with a roster scroll
list that they would
have to flick through
to find their characters
or ships to assign
to their squad for that event.
So we designed a
roster search filter,
which for non-keyboard
users gives quick access
for selecting different
classifications
and factions of characters
and for keyboard users
allows them to quickly
type and search
for any different type of
characters they're looking for.
And this is a feature that
we've gotten great feedback
on that's provided value
to both types of users.
Now, our next case study--
and this is the one that I'm
kind of most excited about-- is
battle keyboard bindings.
This goes back to the
social media aspect here.
Everybody on the subreddit
who's talking about emulators
is saying, they're
using emulators
for faster combat,
better interaction
with their characters,
ease of ability switching.
And from that, we
were able to build
this piece of
functionality that exists
on top of our existing
battle function.
So listen to your player base
and design new and exciting
ways to interact with your
existing game features that
are very keyboard-focused and
provide a better experience.
Finally-- and this one is
going to seem really obvious--
almost every game out
there has some sort
of in-game chat functionality.
But this, in my mind,
is the perfect example
of why polish is important.
Let's say you take the base
game with chat functionality.
You're in battle, you
see a chat UI icon,
you're able to
open a chat dialog,
and you're able to
interact with your guild.
Now, there are a couple pieces
of friction within that flow.
You have to first tap the
icon, go into the prompt,
focus the text entry box,
and then start typing.
That's not
keyboard-focused design.
We have the ability to
detect these keyboard users.
So let's take advantage of that.
Let's give these users
a spacebar macro,
for example, that allows
them to easily open and close
the chat dialog.
Let's detect if these
users have a keyboard,
and then let's automatically
focus the text entry box,
so that they can immediately
start typing and interacting
with the chat feature.
Those are very simple
pieces of work,
very low lift, low
effort, but they
improve the keyboard
experience just that much more.
In addition to these key
considerations for designing
your features or new features
around keyboard-focused design,
there are additionally a number
of special considerations
that we've encountered.
One key thing that many
Unity developers probably
have already encountered is
the concept of KeyCode.Escape.
Now, out of the
box, Unity is going
to surface the hardware back
button and the hardware escape
key on a Chromebook keyboard
as the same input event,
as a KeyCode.Escape.
So one thing that you can
do to work around this
is extend your Android
activity for your Unity app,
handle input there
around these two cases,
and then trampoline those values
back to your manage game code.
Another option to
consider is a compromise.
For your escape key and
your hardware back button
functionality, consider
prompting the user,
instead of just hard quitting
or hard minimizing out
of the application.
Another key consideration is
that of Unity iOS keyboard
support.
This is really important
to keep in mind.
I've talked to a number of
people who have developed
around keyboard entry.
They take an iPad, they get
a Bluetooth keyboard, hook
up the Bluetooth
keyboard, see that they
can enter emails and
iMessage, enter the game,
and have no idea why their
keyboard functionality
isn't working.
Unfortunately, right now,
there are some limitations
around how Bluetooth input
is handled on iOS devices,
specifically with respect to
how Unity services those input
events.
So I suggest for the
time being, if you
detect that the device is
ARC compatible, by default
enable keyboard features.
Get your keyboard users
into those keyboard
features that you've spent
all this time polishing.
If it's a general
Android device, which
is standard compliant
with Bluetooth keyboards,
default your keyboard
functionality off
and give users an option to then
enable keyboard functionality
if they want to.
On an iOS device,
however, at this time,
I recommend disabling
keyboard input,
because it can provide a
confusing experience to users.
Now, we've got a lot of
engineers in the room,
so this is preaching to
the choir, and I apologize.
But as with any sort
of side quest project
or any sort of support
or retrofitting
around a new platform,
focus on minimizing coupling
and ensure maintainability.
That's a lot of words,
there's a lot of jargon there.
Let me give you a
specific example of that.
Going back to the battle
keyboard bindings, now,
I know many people
in the audience
are probably thinking about how
they might implement something
like this in their
own game right now.
And there are many
ways to do so.
One of the first
approaches, which
might be somewhat naive with
respect to this statement,
is taking those
battle ability icons
and directly coupling the
display and functionality
of those keyboard macros with
the battle ability icons.
Now, that's probably
an easy way to get
this functionality started
and get it going in your game.
However, the downside
is now you've
introduced a coupling between
your keyboard functionality
and the core mechanics
of battle in your game.
This isn't good.
You're going to end
up in a situation
where you've pat
yourself on the back,
you've gotten awesome
keyboard-focused features
in your game, you have
Chromebook support,
months in the future
an engineer is
going to roll onto
the project, they're
going to have to redesign some
core mechanic of your battle
ability system.
And they're are going to be
stuck maintaining your keyboard
binding code.
So instead for this
example, consider
having an overlay,
where you pin those UI
elements on the abilities,
detect them at the time
that you're in battle,
and then do something
like simulate an input press.
It's not exactly elegant, but
it at least removes the coupling
from your keyboard functionality
and your battle ability system.
Now, I'm going to turn
the microphone back over
to Ben for some more
technical considerations.
BEN GABLE: Thanks, Daniel.
So as we saw from
Daniel, thinking
about how you can optimize your
game on this new form factor
is really a huge benefit.
And there's a possibility there.
So we're going to go over some
of the technical aspects you
should consider when optimizing
your game for Chromebooks.
So first off, it's
the real Android.
So it is Android
running side by side
with Chrome OS and Chromebook.
So you've got access
to all the things
you would expect in Android.
And as Daniel mentioned,
the first step
is kind of already done for you.
So if your app is published
on the Play Store right now,
it's already running
on Chromebooks.
That might freak some of
you out, but don't worry.
I would say you're probably
80% to 90% of the way there.
You're using the same APK
for both mobile devices
and Chromebooks.
So let's go over some common
issues, some best practices,
and some of the
testing and tools
that you have available when
optimizing for Chrome OS.
So the first thing we're
going to talk about
is targetSdkVersion
and 64-bit support.
So Chrome OS is currently
running Android M. P
is coming later this
summer, which is awesome,
because there are some
cool mouse capture APIs
that we'll have there.
But you have to target at
least API level 24 in order
to get all of the freeform
resizing functionality
in your game.
If you don't do that, your
game will restart whenever
you get a configuration change.
So it's important to
target at least 24.
But as mentioned
earlier, this fall, we're
going to require you
to target Android O.
So it's a good idea
to start working
on this now rather than later.
Your minimum API level
doesn't need to change.
And some things you might run
into are permission updates--
we've talked about
it a bit earlier--
and some background
execution changes as well.
So first thing you should
do is start looking
at your targetSdkVersion.
So some features and
sensors are actually
incompatible with Chromebook.
So for example, if
your game is asking
for using GPS, or NFC,
or stuff like that,
those are not supported
on Chromebook.
So it's going to show up as
not compatible with your device
on the Play Store.
So you want to make sure that
you remove those permissions,
if you're not using them, or add
required equals false in order
to prevent it from being
filtered out on the Play
Store for any Chromebook users.
If you do that, however, just
make sure to dynamically check
in your code these features
are available before you
try to use them.
Otherwise, things will blow up.
And that's never fun.
And some permissions also
imply feature requirements.
So it's kind of a small list.
It's on the Developer page.
But if you're looking
for like SMSs or stuff
like that to send out
maybe invites to friends
lists or whatever, your app will
be filtered from Chromebook.
So it's important to just
double-check your permissions
and features to
make sure there's
nothing that could be filtering
it out on Chromebooks.
So the other big set of common
issues is around the display.
So dynamic resizing by default
is enabled if your API level
target is greater than 24.
So in a lot of cases can
cause flickering or texture
stretching.
And especially with a
lot of game engines,
it doesn't handle it very well.
Because in the gaming
world, PC, we kind of
expect things to be at a set
resolution as a locked aspect
ratio.
So what we kind of recommend
is that, if you can't support
dynamic resizing, which we
encourage you take a look at,
you can always set resizable
activity equal to false
in your manifest in order to
prevent Chrome OS from allowing
your app to dynamically resize.
One thing you should
keep a note is that it
has to be on the root activity.
So we've seen some cases
where if you happen
to use a different
launch mode or something,
it will ignore this setting.
So you just have to
make sure that that
is set on your root activity.
Another thing to
take into account
is that Chromebooks
are convertibles.
You can put them in
laptop mode, tablet mode.
And upside down apps are bad.
So how do we prevent this?
So basically what
you want to do is,
if you are checking your code
and determining the orientation
based on that, you
want to make sure
that you're using
display getRotation
and you're taking into account
that portrait mode might not
always be rotation 0.
So you want to swap
your axis accordingly,
if you are doing this
in code dynamically,
because it's going to be
different from your mobile
device to Chromebooks.
However, easiest way
to get to handle this
is to just specify sensor
orientations in your manifest.
So you can specify
portrait or landscape.
And then if you do
that, just make sure
that you don't specify
one thing in the manifest
and then try to do something
different in the code later on.
You'll make Chrome OS go crazy.
Another thing to
take into account
is that if you have
a portrait mode game
and you play it in a full
screen landscape setting,
you might want to add some
flowers or other cool stuff
on the sides there to
prevent the ugly black bars.
So it's just something
to think about.
So another thing
that's on Chrome OS
is input compatibility mode.
So what this aims to
do is it basically
tries to just make touch-based
games and apps just
work, which makes sense,
because most of the apps
and games on Google Play right
now for mobile devices only
expect touch inputs.
So it basically translates
mouse and trackpad events
to touch events under the hood.
This might not be
the best if you're
trying to actually
optimize your game
and take advantage of
mouse and trackpad events.
So what you can
do is you can tell
Chrome OS you're targeting
PC-type hardware by specifying
the following in your manifest.
And then you can check the
source of your motion events
to actually determine
where this is coming from.
So once you do that, you
can do things like listen
for mouse hovering,
scrolling, stuff
like that, all these nice
things that users would expect
when playing with a mouse.
So a really good example of
this is "Minecraft, Story Mode."
Telltale basically
dynamically checks
to see if the user is playing
with a keyboard and mouse.
And if they are, they change the
input mode to basically support
from their touch-base
control scheme
to their desktop PC and
mouse type control scheme.
So it really works really
well, and it's seamlessly.
And so if you're looking
for a great example,
I recommend that
you check that out.
So let's talk about
some best practices now.
Targeting compatible
Chromebooks--
so not all Chromebooks are
going to support touch or even
have touch screens.
A lot of them do right
now, but it's not
something you should
rely on in the future.
So you should make
sure that you specify
that you don't
require a touchscreen,
because of a faketouch feature.
Otherwise, again,
your app or game
will get filtered out from
the Google Play Store.
You can also ex-- we
don't recommend this,
but if you want to
exclude specific devices,
you can always do so through
the Google Play Console.
But we recommend that
you try to support
as many devices as possible.
So mouse and keyboard--
probably one of the biggest
best practices we can suggest is
to support mouse and keyboard.
So what does that actually mean?
Well, detecting
clamshell versus tablet
is one, showing contextual
control prompts, and consider
accessibility menus and UI.
So again, "Asphalt 8"
detects that you're
using a keyboard when
you start up the game.
And it will actually show
you your control scheme
based on which control
scheme you're using.
So if you're playing
in tablet mode,
which works great,
not so great when
you're playing with a laptop.
So they will change the
control prompts when you're
playing with keyboard and mouse,
so that users aren't confused
when they're sitting there,
and they're like, what,
do I have to pick up my
laptop and play with it?
So definitely keep that in mind.
If you're using Unity, luckily
detecting a mouse and keyboard
is pretty easy.
You can just use a
standard input class
to detect keyboard
and mouse input.
If you're using Java, you can
do something a little bit more
interesting, where basically
you can pull the input manager
and basically figure out if
your device has a hardware
keyboard and mouse
and then maybe
toggle some kind of
input mode to say,
I'm playing on a
desktop environment
versus I'm playing on
a mobile environment.
So those are some
ideas in how you
might detect the different
environment you're
in and providing the right
control scheme for your users.
And Daniel kind of talked
about some of these ideas
for keyboard.
But things like skill
keybindings, navigation,
menu navigation, extra credit,
custom key mappings, these
are all things that would
really be appreciated
by users on Chrome OS.
If you're using gamepads,
which some of you are,
it supports for up to 4 and
it uses all the standard APIs
for reporting.
So you're set there.
And performance
front, so Chromebooks
support the Pixelbooks and
some of the newer [INAUDIBLE]
like devices, all
support Vulkan 1.0.
1.1 is coming soon.
So this is rolling out
across different devices.
So definitely take advantage
of that, if you can.
Also try to provide
an x86 build.
There's a lot of Chromebooks
that have x86 processors.
And there is some overhead
with Houdini ARM translation.
So just keep that in
mind, that if you can,
it's best to provide
an x86 build,
so that you can take
advantage of that.
And also, you should be careful
with dynamic performance
optimizations in your game.
So Chrome OS is based
using a compositor.
And it can totally
screw up-- you
could get into situations
where you end up
with quadruple buffering based
on how the compositor is doing.
So you might want to
think about testing,
if you're doing any kind
of dynamic optimizations,
to make sure that you could
be getting requesting buffers
and getting them
back super fast.
And you might get
one buffer that
takes it some time
because of the compositor.
So that could totally screw
up your dynamic performance
optimizations.
So that's something
to test and just
keep in mind when you're trying
to optimize for Chrome OS.
So testing and tools--
you want to make sure that you
test your old and new flows.
So moving forward, our goal
is to keep Chrome OS in line
with--
the Android version in line
with your mobile devices,
so there's not a lot of big,
large, breaking changes.
But with that said,
when you first
start bringing your
game over to Chrome OS,
you want to make sure
you test the Close
button in the
upper right corner,
make sure that your app
isn't dynamically resizable,
if you're saying
it's not resizable,
minimizing, maximizing,
x86 builds, ARM builds.
You just want to make sure
that there's no gotchas.
The Android lifecycle is the
same across Android and Chrome
OS.
So it should all be
the same, but there
might be some gotchas
you should just test for.
And the Chrome OS
emulator is now available.
It's integrated
with Android Studio.
And it has hardware
acceleration.
This is a great tool
if you're developing
to quickly test any kind
of performance or issues
with your game.
And also big news is that ADB
over USB is now available.
It's coming out to
Chromebooks, rolling out
to the different models.
Previously, you had
to attach over Wi-Fi,
which obviously is kind of
not ideal in some cases.
But we're slowly
rolling this out.
And you should watch the
keynote later this week
for more information on this.
But this is also a really
big win for Chromebooks.
And for profiling and debugging
APKs, in Android Studio 3
and up, you can now import any
debuggable APK or Unity Gradle
project and actually take
advantage of the Android
Profiler for things like
CPU, memory, network usage.
So that's super-- it's
a really handy tool.
And I recommend you
all check it out.
And we have a lot of
developer resources
on developing and
optimizing for Chrome OS.
So I'd recommend
that you definitely
go check out our developer
pages for all the even more
nitty gritty than this talk.
And also our developer
blog, there's
some very specific
posts that we've
written on specific
aspects of Chromebook.
So if you're looking
for more in-depth topics
or in-depth knowledge,
you should check that out.
So to recap, we're really
excited about the possibility
of Chromebooks now that we
can play on a mobile app,
take it to your big screen,
when at home on your Chromebook.
And it really opens up, I
think, the way you can present--
using Chromebooks,
you can provide
the best possible experience
for your mobile game.
And as we've seen,
we've got lots
of partners that are doing this
and taking advantage of it.
And they're finding out
it's a great opportunity,
like our friends from "Roblox."
And they're finding out
it's not a lot of work.
80% to 90% of the way, just
the keyboard and mouse,
some testing, and now, you've
got this whole, new set
of users that can enjoy and play
your mobile game in the best
way possible.
So we're super excited.
We think our
partners are excited.
And we hope you all
take advantage of it.
So as I mentioned, there's an
I/O session later this week,
where we're going to talk
about, not specifically games,
but just kind of
Chrome OS in general.
There's a lot of
cool stuff that's
going to be in that talk.
So if you're going to I/O,
definitely check it out.
And as a special
surprise, Chromebooks--
so we have a bunch
of Chromebooks,
and we're going to give one
to each company that is here
today.
So what we're going
to do is, please
come find me during the mixer.
I'm going to be sitting back
over there with those boxes.
And one representative
from your company, we'll
give you a Samsung
Chromebook Pro.
So we hope that you
guys take that back.
If you already have one,
take another one, test on it,
please check it out.
And we think that you'll be
surprised at how well it works.
And hopefully, it
inspires all of you
to optimize your
games for Chrome OS.
So thank you.
If there's any questions, I
don't know if we have any time,
you can email me, or we'll
answer some right now.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
So I'm always looking
for great Android TV
games for [INAUDIBLE] TV.
And it seems that with the
lack of touchscreen support,
you can't obviously assume
touchscreen support,
as you mentioned, and
with controller support,
HIT support.
How much overlap is there
between Android games
for Chromebook and Android
games for Android TV?
BEN GABLE: Android TV.
So I'm not super
familiar with Android TV,
what the overlap is.
But I think, in general,
it's just another--
it's another space where you're
not going to have a touchscreen
or you're going to have to
think about these other methods
of input that will just
make your game work if you
don't have a touchscreen.
I don't know if that
answers your question.
Or like, what specifically
do you mean by the overlap?
AUDIENCE: Well, for example,
Android TV, you're quite--
for the recording, Android
TV doesn't have icons,
it has banners, because
it's a different format.
And the launcher is different,
the Leanback Launcher.
How much of what you do
code-wise and design-wise
for games on Chrome
OS can you then take
to make a great
game for Android TV?
BEN GABLE: I see.
I think it's all work
that all plays together.
So if you're optimizing
for Android TV
and you're adding all
these keyboard and mouse
input-- or keyboard
or computer inputs,
it all kind of filters back
into Chromebooks as well.
So thinking about
implementing in your game
other methods of
input and other ways
that users might be
interacting with your game,
it all plays together
into making an app--
a game that can run on
Android TV, on Chromebooks,
on tablets, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BEN GABLE: Yep.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: Are you guys
going to be putting together
a highlight reel of Chrome
OS apps running on--
or I'm sorry, Android
running on Chrome OS.
Because that was
our other thing when
we're trying to get
our developers to be
excited about it, like
this is another platform,
it's another chance for
you to reach more users.
But they look at it, and they
say, well, that's more work.
So we want to be able to
make sure it's something
that we can highlight when
it's being put in well.
And we can point
to other developers
and say, that's what
we're looking for,
that's the kind
of functionality,
that's the sort of user--
The "Galaxy of Heroes"
examples were incredible.
That's the kind of stuff
that our devs need.
BEN GABLE: Yeah.
So there is-- this is a reel
that's happening at the I/O
keynote that I believe will
be uploaded to YouTube as
well, if you don't
have an I/O ticket.
Also, when you get the
Chromebook, in the Google Play
Store, we're
highlighting games that
have been optimized very well.
So it's an actual
featured banner in there.
So you'd be able to
download apps and test them
out and just kind of see what
other games might be doing
and how you could potentially
take some of those ideas
and filter it into your game.
AUDIENCE: Fantastic, thanks.
BEN GABLE: Any other questions?
Cool.
If there's more questions,
feel free to shoot me an email.
I'll be around at the mixer too.
So thanks a lot.